[Music]
[Applause]
were you a young child that never wanted
to get your hair done you never want to
put a comb or a brush through it you
were more than happy with your hair
being wild free in its natural state
well this was me I hate it I mean I hate
it getting my hair done and every other
Saturday I would have to go get my hair
done some days I would get twist some
days I would get braids but for the most
part I got my hair straightened the
results were always beautiful but the
process was quite traumatic because my
hair was so thick I would go through
hours of boredom and even sometimes pain
at first it was my mother dragging me to
these gruesome appointments but over
time I started to crazies hair styles
for myself and it became a part of my
routine why would I go through this over
and over again
it's just hair right well how many of
you guys have went to a hairstylist and
they cut off way too much of your hair
or how many of you guys have even been
embarrassed just by a bad hair day
the truth is it isn't just hair we all
put extra time and effort into our hair
because it means something to us and as
a young african-american woman I've been
taught the art of manipulation growing
up
I'm not only putting earnest amount of
money but time and energy into changing
my hair I've had an abundance of
hairstyles but my go-to was the relaxer
for those of you who do not know the
relaxer is a chemical treatment that
permanently straightens curly coily hair
here are two pictures of me as a child
the one to the left I was about five
weeks old and the one to the right I was
about six or seven years old the picture
of me as a baby is one of the only
pictures I have
national hair the rest of my childhood
pictures are of me with relaxed hair
with relaxed hair my hair was more
manageable more presentable natural hair
doesn't lay flat
it doesn't even grow downward but
instead outward like a tree and because
of this my hair was inappropriate and I
never questioned this fact it was just
something I knew to agree with now I
always knew how to maintain my hair in
these hairstyles but I was never taught
how to love the hair that I was born
with and I believe that is the main
problem you have to love parts of
yourself in order to love your whole
self now why aren't young black girls
taught to love their hair well there was
a time where all black women were
natural then have access to chemical
treatments or tools to straighten it
there were kinks curls and coils all
throughout their hair until someone told
them that it wasn't beautiful not just
some one but multiple people as much as
we hate to bring it up slavery created a
Eurocentric standard of beauty this
means that only Eurocentric features
were deemed beautiful such as light skin
pointy noses and last but not least
straight hair black woman gave into this
false pretense and decided to create
some solutions all of previous methods
were used the hot comb became one of the
most popular methods to be used which is
kind of comparable to a modern Flatiron
but then the holy grail was discovered
the relaxer this product swept African
American consumers offer their feet and
started flying off the shelves
not only did women use this product but
men did too I mean y'all James Brown had
a relaxer
this compliance to altering our own hair
contributed to the underlying hatred of
natural hair and now African Americans
were brainwashed to believe that their
own hair was too nappy it's too while it
isn't thought to be long enough or even
in some cases professional it isn't good
hair because of its texture and
thickness now even today I hear fellow
black woman saying well that's her hair
is it for everybody well what is that
supposed to mean the hair that grows out
of my scalp isn't for me
the hair that I was born with isn't for
me as silly as that might sound the
relaxer created this thought and people
thought that it made good hair
attainable it made the impossible
possible even I got entangled into the
magic of this product with long straight
hair I was beautiful and accepted I was
so focused on how I was being perceived
black girls were known for having short
nappy hair but not me I started to place
the burden on myself of being the black
girl with the long good hair I loved
being the person that defied that
stereotype and because of this I wore my
hair straight for the majority of my
life
it wasn't until high school that I
thought maybe this way of thinking is
flawed I saw a revival in the natural
hair community black women were starting
to ditch the relaxers all down my
youtube timeline was natural hair videos
businesses began to release more
products than ever catered to ethnic
hair so I thought why not switch it up
I'll go natural I went natural strictly
to experiment with my hair but I never
knew the self-love and journey that
would take me on in order to go natural
you can do so in two ways you can either
a big chop or transition a big chop is
when you
all the relaxed hair and start fresh
however transition is when you let that
hair grow out over time gradually
cutting it and I saw much shows both
choices for about a year I transition
but as I was about a year in the
detangling became too hard for me my
roots were so curly it might end or just
stick straight so I thought I was like
I'm gonna cut off all my hair and my
cousin and I snuck out to a hair cutter
II defy my mother's wishes and as I was
in the chair I felt good I felt
empowered I felt in control Society
wasn't going to control me I was going
to lead by example however as soon as I
stepped out of that chair that amazing
feeling soon faded away I thought to
myself how God feels so powerful and
then the next minute still so powerless
I looked in the mirror and didn't
recognize myself I had to face the real
me I never knew how much I was hiding
behind my hair until that day I was
never an insecure person but I started
to lack confidence my proud title was
taken away from me mother knows best
right because I felt that I had just
made a huge mistake all of my life I had
long straight hair now
I had short curly hair this was more
than a haircut for me this was a
lifestyle change I was no longer
subscribing to societal demands but I
wasn't prepared for the consequences of
that either some people liked my hair
some people didn't some of my friends
said oh how brave it was to do that and
how they just loved the look of it they
said it was so cute and it was so curly
on the other hand I had comments that I
looked way better with straight hair
they was saying why did you cut your
hair off it was so beautiful key word
was my hair was no longer deemed
beautiful and the negative comments
stung because I was still trying to love
my natural hair myself all the youtubers
I had watched fell in love with their
natural hair instantly so why didn't I
but I thought to myself why don't people
like natural hair but more importantly
why don't I and the answer is it's
because we're taught not to I had to
train myself to think like and for
myself it didn't matter what people
thought it was my hair and they didn't
like the real me then they didn't like
me at all I started to love and accept
my own hair for what it was
I love the untamed look of it the way
that my hair defies gravity is something
that I think is beautiful now I think
why would I go back Street why would I
ever do that to myself why would I fight
Who I am anymore
I'm not going to do it and today we live
in a world full of constant manipulation
in all areas not just hair we have such
access to technology that makes it so
easy for you to change yourself if you
don't like your body get plastic surgery
if you don't like your crooked teeth you
can get braces but hair is different yes
you can manipulate it but you can cut it
off and start all over at any point in
time and at one point society is going
to try to straighten your hair it's
going to try to curl your hair try to
manipulate your hair and it's going to
tell you not to love your hair and
ultimately not to love yourself now this
is how I wear my hair 90% of the time by
no means is it perfect but it's a part
of me some days it might be elongated
some days it might be curled up in a
little bush and that is something that
I'm totally okay with
times some time I was still straighten
my hair change up my look because I do
love the versatility that African
Americans have created there is nothing
wrong with changing your look but the
key lies in managing that look wear a
different look but don't let that look
become you because you are good enough
naturally thank you
[Applause]